Le joining me now is Ben de Menage
editor in large of The Spectator and a
Fox News contributor and Phil kirp and
president of the committee to unleash
Prosperity Ben we're going to talk later
in the show about where the GOP goes
from here but what's your take on what
happened last night starting in Virginia
well first off I have to say as a
Virginia for the you know three decades
of My Life um people need to recognize
it's a blue State and it's not the first
time that Republican candidates both
hardcore social conservatives and people
who were Washington Insider moderates
you know Ken Cinelli Ed Gillespie they
both had to deal with the problem of
navigating the abortion issue in that
state they both lost very close
elections uh and that's the kind of
issue that's a real Challenge in a
socially liberal state in a state that
Joe Biden won by 10 points Glenn yunan
came extremely close to achieving
Republican ends and he did so after a
redistricting that affected a number of
these races situations where you had
very close elections where they added
you know 177,000 votes in particular
particular to one critical senate seat
from the Democrat side it's really hard
to go up against that but it's even
harder when someone like Ron McDaniel at
the RNC does not come in and offer any
support in Virginia okay and that's
actually what I would be pointing the
finger at if I was any Republican in
Virginia saying look how close we got we
got this slim margin away from achieving
something that could have made this
governorship extremely effective over
the next two years but you didn't give
any money toward it you refused the
request they have the money well that's
a big question too I mean that is it's a
fair question and but the fact that she
refused the request that came from the
Virginia Republicans for that last
minute help in October that could have
been the margin there a few million
dollars here or there could have made
the difference in these State Senate ele
but again I'm not to I don't want to pin
the blame on one person here because
it's not just one person there were a
lot of political Consultants that got
rich off these Virginia races and no
matter how wrong they are they always
get hired again I I never understood
this about the political consol I got to
go on that business cuz I give much
better advice fa upwards fa upward fail
upwards exactly but Phil given the the
the financial disparity here clearly
Republicans don't have the money that
the Democrats have how to connect that
workingclass message that obviously
works in Miami Dade County it
works well look I think it's interesting
that uh the biggest win in Virginia was
actually a race where the Republican had
almost no money it was a Commonwealth
Attorney race in Lowden County the
Republican I think spent $70,000 against
an incumbent who spent 1.1 million um
wait wait for and what race was this
again the Commonwealth Attorney Buddha
Bai Biber who spent $1.1 million lost
that was loud in County Lowden County
she lost because she criminalized
parents standing up for their children
in the schools and refused to prosecute
the actual criminals in the schools and
that did have enough legs to extend
through another election cycle although
it wasn't enough to dominate Statewide
the way that it was so Bob and won that
seat Arlington Arlington Virginia
liberal Fairfax county is so liberal now
it's not in any way moderate it was in
the 80s uh mid 80s when I came here
Fairfax County Northern Virginia was
kind of workingclass very moderate
Republican that's totally changed and
Ben immigration has changed a lot in
Virginia has it not it really has and
open border is going to make it worse it
really has but I also think this is this
is a failure for Republicans to
recognize you have a new Coalition now
and you're not going back to the old one
okay you may have fond memories at the
point where you had those uh you know
upper class wine moms in the suburbs you
know coming out and voting for you in
midterm elections but guess who's voting
for you now it's the guy who's building
the deck out behind her house okay so
you have to appeal to him you have to
reach out to him you have to bring him
to the poll to that point Phil are are
Republicans investing in Spanish radio
because there's an enormous amount of
Hispanic radio and television that seems
to me to be fertile ground for common
sense messaging on policies I'm not
hearing any anything and are you hearing
any ads in Spanish I speak Spanish I
haven't heard any ads very little and
it's a huge missed opportunity look I I
think that uh Ben is absolutely right
Republicans are now the party of people
who work for a living okay the Democrats
are the party of the very rich and the
party of people who are on government
assistance government dependency and for
Republicans to win they need to run up
the score with everyone who's in the
middle economically and Laura I wish
they would carry the message exactly
like you did in your monologue there
because that's a winning message on the
economy and when when I'm president gas
is going to be 230 a gallon again how
does that sound exactly what I what I
have such a big what I have such a big
problem with though is look I mean I
agree with you Virginia is a tough State
we did all right we picked up some seats
the map was tough but we've got a
president who's a total failure toal
dister with a horrible rating we should
be able to win an environment like this
and it's almost political malpractice
that we're not they R abortion in
Virginia it's political malpractice that
we let Democrats run away from Joe Biden
and their the responses on abortion are
simply not up to up to the scale that
they need to be how did Trump do it what
did Trump say Hillary you're the radical
you want to rip babies out of the woms
of offense he went on offense for 20 and
accomplish more than people who are
scared to talk about running away from
it lets Democrats Define you on the
issue you can't avoid it anymore State
local this is in your territory now you
can't get away with dodging it you have
to come up with an answer and you have
to deliver it the genius of what Trump
did is I think most voters he says
Hillary you want to rip babies out and
I'm most voters who don't vote on that
issue say oh they're both crazy I'll
vote on the economy I'll vote on
something else but if you don't to if
you don't give them something to think
they're both radic when when do you
think baby when when does a baby have
rights I have I have an idea it's a
crazy idea maybe let's start with having
an actual organized pro-life movement in
the country and then see if there's
something that benefits from that yeah
and and dos what people say was it worth
it to have Ro versus weight overturn
absolutely not even a question that is
like the dumbest question I heard all
day um both of you great to see you
thanks so much hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interview and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else